is joining us now with more while the
chairwoman for the victims rights reform
Council who gave really powerful
testimony earlier today
we welcome Madeline Brauns with us thank
you
first of all
as a parent I am so sorry you lost your
son
thank you and you and his father was
stabbed yes life-changing life-altering
injuries
okay
I watched you say that Alvin Bragg is
treating you and your family like
garbage
[Music]
explain
Alvin Bragg was handled a strong
trial-ready murder case from the
original disc attorney all right these
original District Attorneys were
professional
they were old school and they had an
airtight trial ready murder case against
all four people this is Psy Vance's Psy
Vance yes okay
soon as Alvin Bragg took office
he was handed
that strong trial midi ready murder case
and the original district attorney
retired like many many of the Adas left
as soon as Alvin Bragg's day one memo
came out about not Prosecuting crime as
soon as his office his new Ada daphna
Iran received that case it immediately
started to fall apart
all of a sudden Mary Saunders and Travis
Stewart they couldn't
prove the guilt
Manhattan couldn't afford
to take all four people the trial
they gave me three they told you they
can't they couldn't afford they don't
have the resources 150 million dollars
to go after Donald Trump exactly exactly
that's like for an unpaid parking ticket
that was one of the excuses that they
gave me you know wow none of it made any
sense none of it made it Donald Trump
ever killed anybody no
no and you said that in your testimony
I'm not I don't care what your politics
are you lost your son that's right and
you said in your in your comments this
is not about politics not about life and
death that's right real people are
affected by this you know album bag
um dismissed both murder and gang
assault indictments against two people
okay
um
one is currently walking the street
amongst us okay
um these are homicidal Maniacs they
brutally
ambushed and butchered my son to death
okay nine times
and then turned and butchered his father
12 times when he tried to come to his
Aid
this is all on video right
I I honestly I'm going to have an
aneurysm sitting here this has got to
stop yes these people belong not only in
jail but in hell you know
your son should be alive today you
mentioned the word in your testimony
today that we don't hear any more
deterrent that's right there are no
deterrents you know when we see the
children all right the young people out
here acting like Savages okay because
there are no deterrents to that behavior
all right this Bale form bear reform
just raise the age all right law that
they put in control I mean I mean in
place it gave them the green light to do
whatever it is they feel like doing to
whomever however whenever with no
consequences and no deterrence okay it's
creating a whole new generation of
career criminals and mass incarceration
because if they are arrested okay they
just let them go let them go let them go
how many mothers would rather get a call
from their child from Rikers Island than
from the coroner telling them where to
go and identify their child's body so
one idiot from California has barely
meant to mentioned Adam Schiff he wanted
to talk about Trump then you have the
comments of Hank Johnson
he called You're a witness in this he's
calling you and others uh
props in a Maga Broadway production yes
so you lose your child his father is
forever injured
and you were you a prop what's your
answer to him no absolutely not you know
I I would challenge this this gentleman
whatever his name is okay Johnson Hank
Johnson to Step One Foot In The Hood
step one foot in the hood and tell me if
those people there in that hood are
props as well
you know he's a BL he's a rich black man
all right he is a rich black man that's
selling poor black men that they're
props and that the crime and the things
that they're experiencing it's it's not
as bad as they think that they are you
know and not just him not just him all
the elected officials you know all of
them especially the ones that are
running New York
all right listen I I can only say and I
know I speak for this audience here in
the audience at home your courageous
woman I know your life will never be the
same again
but just know that there are a lot of us
that hear your cry and for justice and
we're praying for it I'm praying for you
I'm praying for your family thank you so
much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else